arriving two hours ahead of the start of
his trial an indication perhaps of how
Keen Kevin Spacey is to come to court to
try to clear his name a wall of
photographers nothing unusual for this
a-lister
but in terms of stages he's appeared on
for Spacey arguably how he comes across
here has never mattered as much
in court the Oscar winner spoke only to
confirm his name his lawyers previously
insisting he welcomes the chance to
finally tell his version of events
see this has gone on now for over a year
back in July 2022 he first appeared in
court denying five allegations relating
to three men between 2005 and 2013. four
counts of alleged sexual assault and one
of causing a person to engage in sexual
activity without consent then in January
of this year additional charges were
added made by a different complainant
alleged to have taken place between 2001
and 2005 including three charges of
indecent assault three of sexual assault
and one count of causing a person to
engage in sexual activity without
consent all of which Spacey has
strenuously denied
best known for starring in modern
cinematic Classics like American Beauty
And The Usual Suspects for the actor
this case has had a devastating impact
on his career it's obviously a cloud
hanging over him he lost a role once the
charges were announced he hasn't really
picked up much work since so until the
outcome is decided I think it's going to
be very difficult for him to get new
work
Spacey was for millions of
Cinema
now with his career hanging in the
balance his fate rests with a much
smaller audience a select group of 12.
the jury now sworn in this trial soon to
get underway Katie Spencer Sky News